hello guys and how you doing welcome to
another video so we've just gotten word
that a secret invasion trailer will
reportedly be played at d23 now this is
a disney event where they normally show
footage and stuff of upcoming tv shows
and movies and sometimes even announce
projects as well so it does make sense
for this to be released but this is also
just a rumor as well and it's a rumor
that comes from daniel rpk but he is a
very very reliable scooper when it comes
to trailers so judging by this and
judging by the event i would say it's an
extremely good chance that we'll get
this trailer and i would say that we'll
even get trailers for other upcoming
marvel stuff like black panther two
because as we know that is releasing
quite soon in a couple of months it only
makes sense to get a first full trailer
for that as well and also if you're not
sure the d23 event begins on september
the 9th and goes into september 11 so we
really only have a couple more days to
go so get keen guys it's exciting to see
what we will see in this event but let
me know in the comment section below on
what you guys think we'll see at this
event and if you haven't already please
do consider subscribing to the channel
and turning notifications on to show
your support thanks for watching guys